[Applause]
5 hi Barbie hi Barbie hi
Barbie the president has just signed a
bill that will end the National
Emergency declar during the pandemic
Taylor Swift and Beyonce's shows are
giving the US economy an actual boost he
we
come who are we could be described as
the summer of strikes it's the first
official day of the S after strike I
think AI is one of the most important
things to be talking about you should
probably run it's actually not ice cre
so good Twitter is now X some are even
calling it the Twitter killer nope
scratch that reverse it Mr chud does Tik
Tok access the home Wi-Fi
network we start in the Middle East
Hamas has launched the biggest attack on
Israel in years the Israeli military say
D over a thousand people were killed we
hear the bullets whistling when they
passed by I must say they're holding
between 200 and 250
hostages we are putting a Complete Siege
on Gaza we're fighting animals and are
acting accordingly No One Is Safe
nowhere in Gaza is
[Music]
safe it is
now 90 Seconds To Midnight 2023 will go
down as the hottest year on record the
dense Haze spreading from New England to
Washington DC witness the M rise the
fires are one of the worst natural
disasters in Hawaii's history the death
toll stands at5 people this was my home
three protesters are under arrest for
interrupting the action we have to act
Southern California is under its first
ever tropical storm watch a once in a
century de deadly deluche slamming Hong
Kong the cop 28 team did not deny using
climate meetings to discuss fossil fuel
deals this is really like a [__]
guarding the head house moment frankly
most companies who have set a net zero
Target don't know how they're going to
get
[Music]
there layoffs are sweeping Corporate
America I got laid off two days ago my
government will continue to take action
to bring down inflation
to ease the cost of living bombastic
sidei a group of orcas appear to be
attacking and even sinking some boats
racing against time to find that missing
submersible
$250,000 a ticket bankman freed now
faces more than a 100 years in prison
First Republic is now the third major
Bank to fail since March rert Murdoch is
to step back and will hand over the
Reigns to his son I'm the eldest boy the
New York Republican is now the sixth
lawmaker to ever be expelled from the
house this entire country has been
bullying me just because I'm a proud gay
thief the house has been paralyzed
without a speak for nearly 3 weeks this
is embarrassing there have been concerns
for months about Senator Feinstein's
Health look at the candles on that cake
this is the oldest man alive string of
uh says Never surrender surrender okay
that is a picture of him surrendering to
Georgia authorities though right I don't
care about totic bro the wind the US
linked the balloon to a vast Chinese
military surveillance program oh they
hit it do you believe our government has
made contact with intelligent
extraterrestrials something I can't
discuss in public setting and now NASA's
first mission to deliver the largest
sample collected from an asteroid to
Earth flames and plumes of smoke lit up
the sky in East Ohio after a train
derailed the deadliest earthquake that
Morocco has suffered in more than 100
years the number of people killed in
earthquakes in turke and Syria has risen
to nearly 50,000 two dams and Four
Bridges
collapsed India's deadliest train crash
in decades it has been one year since
Russia began its full-scale invasion of
Ukraine if Russia stops fighting and
leaves Ukraine the war ends if Ukraine
stops fighting Ukraine ends fighting
intensifies between Sudan's armed forces
and the rebel rapid support forces over
1500 Pro Bonar supporters had been
arrested after they stormed government
buildings in Brazilia the situation in
Manipur has been tense the photos
confirm news that no parent wants to
hear a fishing boat sinking with
hundreds on board hundreds of migrants
now 1.7 million Afghans have been told
to leave
Pakistan Palestinians are dying in the
tens of thousands but we'll continue to
say it is us who are not acknowledging
Humanity tens of thousands showing their
support for the Palestinian
people they want our people dead want K
the Israel Hamas War sparking an
increase in islamophobia and
anti-Semitism yet another Mass SHO in
this country 10 people are dead in
Louisville Kentucky at elementary school
in Nashville no way in the world y'all
are trying to ban Tik Tok and y'all
haven't even flinched and changing their
gun
laws Memphis Police have just released
the footage from the death of Tyrie
Nichols those five officers were
arrested and charged with second deegree
murder US Marine captured on video
putting Jordan Neely in a choke hole
affirmative action is gone Catholic
priest can now bless same-sex couples
six justices ruled that certain
businesses can refuse to serve gay
people new laws in Uganda BR that anyone
having gay sex can be jailed for life I
got some Bud Lights for
us yeah Wen we supposed to vote today
what Mexico's Supreme Court has declared
loudly and clearly that access to
abortion care is a human right Ohio now
marks the seventh state since Ro V was
overturned where abortion rights
supporters prevailed I want a big life I
want to experience everything I want to
break every single rule there
is this is a Beacon of Hope and
possibilities I just egot come on in the
Box in front go Spain wins the World
Cup I don't pray for results I just ask
that I get the strength to give it my
all Israel and M agreeing on a deal that
will free a number of hostages I've
still got hope because I know we are
still here and we will never quit India
is on the
moon we choose to go back to the moon
and then on to Mars and we're going to
do it
[Applause]
together we are being asked to love the
extraordinary species that is humankind
and keep it alive
life that's all this
is